all right uh
welcome
everyone to the ddps seminar uh before
we introduce our invited speaker let's
go over some rules and logistics uh
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions if
you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end second
today's gdpr seminar is open to external
audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is a an honor and it's my pleasure
especially because
today's speaker i
know
very well
who is masayano
he is a assistant professor in the
university of toronto institute for
aerospace studies
he obtained his bachelor's degree in
aerospace engineering from georgia tech
master's degree
in computation for design and
optimization from mit and phd in
aerospace computational engineering from
mit
his research interests lie in the
development and assessment of numerical
methods for pdes
with emphasis on adaptive high order
methods error estimation
model reduction and data simulations
i know he's giving a
very
very good talk so you can anticipate a
wonderful talk from masa
today masala will talk about
words reliable efficient and automated
model reduction of parameterized
nonlinear pdes
error estimation adaptivity
and application to aerodynamics all
right
now without further ado let me pass the
button to masa
by asking one random question as you
joule today's random question is what is
your favorite things to do other than
research master other than research and
teaching i i guess
i actually enjoy playing tennis quite a
bit ah so
yeah so that's that's my
i love tennis too we should play
sometime oh we should play something
when we have uh in person meetings at
some point yeah yeah exactly exactly all
right how the stage are yours hamasa
okay so yongsu thank you very much for
the invitation to give a talk here and
thank you everybody for being here um
so today as young said i'm going to talk
about our work towards reliable
efficient and automated model reduction
of parametrized non-linear pdes
and recurring themes for this talk will
be error estimation adaptation and
application to aerodynamics
now before i get started i'd like to
acknowledge the contribution of my
students jeff eugene ben adrian and
michael
what i'm going to present here is really
a product of their work
i would also like to acknowledge the
financial support provided by natural
sciences and engineering research
council of canada canada foundation for
innovation and sign it which provide
computational resources
so in today's talk we'll be looking at
parameterized partial differential
equations so these are problems where we
start with a set of parameters mu and
then given the parameter we compute the
state u of mu and given the state we
evaluate the output s of mu
for example in aerodynamics parameter
could describe flight condition like
angle of attack and mach number
it can also describe shape things like
span chord or even airfoil geometry
and also model parameters for example
associated with turbulence models
and then given these set of parameters
that describe the problem we want to
compute the state velocity pressure
density and so on and then ultimately
evaluate the quantities of interest or
outputs things like lift drug and moment
on aerodynamic body
now we would like to solve this
parameterized problems in many query
scenarios
so here we are thinking about scenarios
like parameter sweep where we might want
to understand the aerodynamic
performance for various mach number and
angle attack
design and optimization where we change
the shape to see how that affect the
performance of the
product and optimize it
and uncertainty quantification where we
want to quantify say the effect of
variability in the input on the
quantities of interest and also
scenarios like unsteady flow prediction
where we might want to say perform flow
control by solving this class of problem
in real time
now one thing that all of these programs
have in common is that they typically
require hundreds or even possibly
millions of simulations so if we try to
use standard cfd method it can become
too expensive so we want to accelerate
the solution of these many query
problems significantly
now one way to do that is to use
surrogate models
so here goal is to construct reliable
efficient pde-informed surrogate models
now one such method that we're going to
talk about is projection-based reduced
order models or the roms
the idea is quite simple in what's
called offline stage we are going to
obtain solutions for training parameters
and then construct a surrogate model so
in the middle i'm showing the parameter
domain we basically sample the parameter
space and then create a reduced order
model
in the online stage once you have that
rom we can invoke that for any parameter
values so go from the parameter mu to
state u of mu to the output and we can
do this um
for parameter values that are not
typically in the training set
so our goal here is to basically create
a surrogate model such that the types of
simulation that might require a
supercomputer can be performed on
something like a laptop
now in terms of mathematical problem we
are looking at
here's the general formula of the
parameterized pd
so we start with a parameter mu that
lies in a p-dimensional space and given
that we found the state u of mu that
satisfies say a conservation laws things
like navier-stokes equations or reynolds
average navier-stokes equations
we then evaluate the output s of mu
again things like lift dragon moment
now there are many parameters pd's out
there in this talk we are going to focus
on aerodynamic flows because they are
complex in the following sense so they
exhibit severe non-linearity
they also exhibit convection dominance
they exhibit wide range of scales in a
sense that things like boundary layers
are so much smaller than the size of an
aerodynamic body
they also exhibit limited regularity
things like shocks
so all of these features makes
aerodynamic flows complex and what we
would like to do is to accelerate the
solution of these types of problems
so here is our goal we would like to
enable model reduction for these complex
pdes and be able to go from parameter to
state to output in rapid reliable and
automated manner
now when i say reddit what i mean is
that we want to provide orders of
magnitude online computational reduction
such that we can solve these many query
problems efficiently
at the same time we also care about
offline training cost we want it to be
efficient such that we can use it in a
practical engineering settings
when i say reliable what i mean is that
we want to provide quantitative online
error estimate in predictive setting
so we want such an error estimate
to be very fast so that we it can
evaluate error estimating the time it
takes to evaluate the itself and also
working predictive setting in the sense
that it works for parameter values that
it wasn't trained for
and in the offline stage we want to use
such an error estimate to adaptively
control various sources of error and
finally we want the entire process to be
automated such that it requires minimum
user intervention or problem specific
tuning
now before we dive into how we approach
this problem i'd like to provide a high
level overview of approximation
hierarchy
so as i mentioned our goal is to solve
parametrized pde
and parameterize pde of course the
solution lies in a sense in an infinite
dimensional space
now in practice we approximate the
solution to this problem by using a full
order model where the solutions
approximate in the nh
dimensional space
for a typical cfd simulation nh might be
in order of a million or so
now reduced order model is further
reduction of that floater model where
the reduced order space might be of
order of 10 to 100 degrees of freedom
but looking at this approximation
hierarchy what this means is that if in
order to construct and accurate wrong we
in fact have to control the error
associated with each one of these
approximations and also estimate error
in order to control the error
so the picture i would like you to keep
in mind is that total error in a reduced
order model is a sum of the full order
model error and the reduced order model
error and ideally what we would like to
be able to do
is that user provide the problem
description
and target tolerance
and automatic algorithm should basically
choose appropriate full order model and
reduced order model such that we can
achieve that error tolerance
and that's what we would like to do
so as a first step i would like to focus
on the control of the full order model
error
to do this we'll be using adaptive iota
method
so in particular we'll be using
discontinuous galactic method so dg
method approximate the solution in the
nh-dimensional piecewise polynomial
space like the one shown on the bottom
right
and given this space we seek a solution
view of h that satisfies the dg residual
statement um which involves integration
over elements as well as facet and given
the solution we evaluate the output
now there are many discretizations out
there but dg methods have number of
attractive features including probes
providing stability for conservation
laws
working with unstructured measures such
that we can mesh complex geometries and
also perform adapt or support adaptive
mesh refinement in an easy manner
and this last piece is going to play a
crucial role as we
try to control the error associated with
the full order model so i'd like to talk
a little bit about how this is done
and here the key is that we want to
control the error associated with the
output so the quantities of interest
things like lift and drag
and in that context not all errors and
residuals are important some errors or
some residuals play more important role
in computing quantities of interest
and one way to understand that is to
solve a dual problem so on the bottom
left i'm showing you an example of the
dual solution we might obtain for
aerodynamic flow
and what this tells us is the
sensitivity of the output
to the residual committed in the various
region of the flow
so by weighing our residual with this
dual solution we can come up with an
error estimate for the quantity of
interest and that is called dual
weighted residual error estimate because
residue is weighted by the duo
we can also localize this statement to
get an elemental error indicator like
the one shown on the right
so in this particular figure what we see
is that for this particular mesh we have
actually a lot of error coming from the
lack of boundary layer resolution for
computing the drug in this case
once we know the arise barge we can
refine the mesh to control the error
and we can keep refining until user
prescribed error tolerance is met
now i'd like to talk a little bit more
about exactly how this adaptation
process work
so this is an iterative procedure we
solve a problem on a given mesh estimate
the error marks the elements for
refinement and then actually refine the
element
as i mentioned the solution is obtained
using the discontinuous galactic method
the estimation is performed using duo
with residual formulation
now in terms of marking we not only want
to know which elements to refine but we
also want to understand how to refine
those elements
so for example you know you can refine
the element in an isotropic manner by
splitting it vertically or horizontally
or an isotropic manner
and this type of anisotropic refinement
can be quite important for aerodynamic
flows which has many anisotropic
features
so let's take a look at how this
particular method works
so throughout this talk i'm going to be
using this flow of our owner m6 wing as
an example so the governing equation is
a reynolds average navier stokes
equation here are the flow parameters
i'm first going to solve this problem
using a kind of a best practice mesh we
might use in aerospace engineering and
using a piecewise linear p1
approximation which corresponds to the
second order method
i i'm going to see how much um
refinement is required to reach 0.5
percent error level so i'm going to
target 0.5 percent because eventually we
are going to split overall error into
0.5 percent for the full order model and
0.5 percent for the reduced order model
to achieve the total error of one
percent
so here is a convergence plot of the cd
era against the number of degrees of
freedom using the second order method on
the sequence of best practice meshes
without adaptation and it requires about
33 million degrees of freedom to achieve
the target error level
now if we perform adaptation
we can reduce that quite significantly
about 5.5 million degrees of freedom so
about a factor of six reduction
we can reduce this further by using high
order methods so using not piecewise
linear polynomial but higher order
polynomials and when we do that we get
this error history so for p 2 through 4
that corresponds to third order to fifth
order method the number of degrees of
freedom required to achieve that 0.5
percent error level goes down to about
0.5 to 0.85 million degrees of freedom
or roughly the fact of 65 reduction
compared to second order mesh a second
order approximation on best practice
measures
so the key takeaway here
is that adaptive high order methods are
very efficient
and this is actually quite important in
the context of reduced order modeling as
well because we still have to train
these models so we want to solve each
one of these problems efficiently such
that in the offline stage we can perform
this calculation um in a
in more quickly than what would be
required we just use the second order
method okay so that's basically what we
are going to be using for full order
model
now the question is that we want to
develop a model reduction method that
works well for these adaptive high order
method
and here is the formulation
our starting point is the selection of
radius spaces i think this is idea that
have come up many many times in these
ddps seminars so the idea here is to
replace this finite element polynomial
space with empirical or terrorized
spaces
and these spaces can be obtained for
example by applying pod or pca on a set
of snapshots
orthogonal bases we obtained might look
like what is shown on the bottom
so this basis basically captures the
parametric variation the solution um
and the parameters are varied
now once we find such a low dimensional
space we can use galactic in projection
to find the solution to the problem
now one caveat here is that even though
we've reduced the dimension of the space
the computation of this residual still
requires order nh operation because we
still have to evaluate the residual all
over the mesh to compute this reduced
residual
now one way to reduce this is to use
hyper reduction so we are going to
accelerate residual evaluation using a
hyper reduction procedure there are many
hyper reduction procedures out there one
particular method we are going to use
is called element wise reduced
quadrature method so the idea here is
that instead of evaluating the residual
on every single element we are going to
evaluate it in a very small subset of
elements
so that we can evaluate this residual
quickly now we want
to choose these reduced quadrature
weights carefully such that we can
provide both sparsity and accuracy so
sparsity simply means that there is
small fraction of the elements are
selected
now accuracy means that we want to make
sure that error in the output due to the
use of this hyper-reduced residual is
small
so we have to somehow control the error
due to hyper reduction
and here we can again appeal to this
idea of dual weighted residual
so use of hyper reduced residual intri
introduces some error in the residual
calculation but we can try to find a set
of weights that minimizes such error and
still achieve sparsity
so the procedure we used to actually
compute that such a weight is called
empirical quadrature procedure
so here basically the user prescribes
the tolerance on the quantity of
interest and then we have an algorithm
that is going to seek a set of weights
that minimizes the number of non-zero
subject three constraints including inc
having non-negative weights
be making sure that it accurate
accurately integrates constant weights
and also satisfying the condition about
residual matching so what the residual
matching means is that even though we
are approximating this residue using
this radial set of weights we want to
make sure that residual is accurate on
the set of training parameter set
now we can solve this problem and the
solution has a number of attractive
properties so first of all the ways that
we find are sparse which is good so that
we can evaluate these hyper-reduced
models
efficiently
second is that it provides error control
under mild assumptions we can prove that
error due to this use of hyper-reduced
residual is controlled to use a
prescribed tolerance
and third computationally set of
constraints becomes linear and this can
be solved efficiently using modified
parallel non-negatively squares
algorithm
and lastly algorithm is quite versatile
so that we can replace this residual
masking matching constraints to hyperuse
various forms and construct things like
error estimate um solving unstudy
problems and so on and i'll demonstrate
this later in the talk
so let's revisit this on era m6 example
and see how it works so this time around
the problem is parameterized we are
still solving reynolds average
navier-stokes equation but we have
certain variation in the mach number as
well as angle of attack reynolds number
is fixed at one million
in terms of error tolerance we are going
to allocate point five percent for full
order model and point 0.5 percent for
the reduced order model
so on the left i'm showing you the
result for using the adaptive dg method
this is basically a summary of the early
graph that we show
and what we see is that in general as
the order of approximation increases
from second order fifth order or p
equals one p equals four number of
degrees of freedom required to achieve
point five percent accuracy goes down
number of elements also goes down
significantly and so does the
computational time so adaptive high
order method enables efficient offline
training
now in terms of the reduced model
constructed this is what we observe so
for this particular problem turns out we
only need about 12 degrees of freedom
about 100 elements are marked after
hyper reduction
but notice that computational time on a
laptop goes up from about 31 seconds to
about 250 seconds and in particular the
speed up relative to the original
floater model in fact decreases as we
use higher order approximation
so somehow this method becomes
increasingly less efficient when we
consider higher order approximation
and this is not so good because we
wanted to create a method that works
well with high order approximations
and the reason for this slow down is
actually twofold so first of all more
computation is required per element for
higher order approximation at least for
dg methods because it involves more
quadrature points by elements
second one is that there are fewer
number of elements to reduce so these
two measures i'm showing you here
achieves about the same amount of error
left second node approximation writes
the fifth order approximation they have
about 0.5 percent um drug tolerance
but
there are basically far fewer elements
for the higher order discretization
which is good from the full order model
computation point of view
but in terms of reduction this means
that there are much fewer opportunities
to actually reduce the problem
so a key takeaway here is that this
element-wise reduce quadrature is not
well suited for this high-order dj
approximation and in fact this
limitations also applies to other
algebraic or discrete hyper-reduction
methods
so how can we fix this problem
now one idea is to work with quadrature
points instead of elements
so instead of decomposing the
in terms of elements we are going to
decompose it further into the level of
the quadrature points which are shown in
blue and red on the right figure
and we are going to use this
as a single unit when we construct our
hyper-reduced residual
the rest is identical so we are still
going to try to approximate the residual
using this hyper-reduced residual but
approximations applied at quadrature
point level and this is shown
pictorially on the bottom right figure
so the gray dots corresponds to the
original quadrature points and we are
selecting a very small subset of those
points to compute the uh
to compute the reduced order model
the algorithm for finding these points
are identical as before so we try to
minimize the number of non-zero subject
to non-negativity constant accuracy and
residual matching conditions
so now let's revisit how this particular
method works
exactly the same method as before on the
left again i summarized the result for
adaptive dj method this time around i
also add the number of quadrature points
so quadrature points varies from about
27 million points to about three million
point for this one era m6 problem
we've already seen the result for
element-based reduced quadrature
basically the time goes up as the quad
as the polynomial degree goes up
with the pointwise method we use little
more points than the number of elements
that was used but in terms of
computational time the computational
time becomes independent of the
polynomial degree that was used
approximately solution so what this guy
achieves is p independent cost and also
it is significantly faster than element
wise method a factor of about 70 000
speed up in terms of cpu time
now you might be worried that reducing
tens of millions of degree um quadrature
points to just hundreds of quadrature
points might require you know
significant training cost because the
optimization program is large but it
turns out this training cost is only
about 30 to 70 percent of a single digit
solved on the final adapted mesh so this
doesn't really cause a significant issue
um in terms of the offline training
so we are quite happy with this
particular method so this is what we are
going to use to construct the rom
now one issue i haven't really addressed
is error estimation and control
now so far what we have done is to
create a rom with efficient offline
training and online evaluation and that
was a product of combining adaptive high
order digi method reduce spaces and
point wise radius culture
so our next goal is to equip this rom
with an estimate of the output error so
we would like to be able to basically
compute the error between the full order
model and reduce the order model in
online efficient manner in predictive
setting
so both of these were important so
online efficient means that evaluation
cost for computing this error estimate
is comparable to just evaluating the rom
and predictive means that this error
estimate has to work even if that model
is not trained for that particular
parameter value
and then once we have such an error
estimate we want to control the error
between floater model and reduce the
model in the automated manner
so i'd like to talk about error
estimation first
so we use the same ingredients that we
that we use to construct an error
estimate for the full order model so
namely the dual weighted residual method
the only difference here is that we are
going to approximate the solution to the
dual problem using reduced basis as well
so just as a short recap the idea is
that we solve the primal or the flow
problem we compute this dual solution
and then by combining them we can come
up with an error estimate for the
quantity of interest
so that's what we are going to do
now one caveat here is that again the
solution of the duo problem also
requires evaluation of the residual so
we have to hyper reduce that as well
and we use exactly the same technique
the empirical quadrature procedure with
a different set of constraints such that
we can also accelerate the evaluation of
this error estimate
and this is an
estimate that can be evaluated in the
online efficient manner
once we have such an error estimate we
can actually automate the training of
the reduced mode of reduced order model
so as a starting point basically user is
going to supply the output tolerances
for finite element and reduce basis
approximation
and then the algorithm is going to
create a reduced order model that meets
user specified tolerance
and idea is the following let's say we
first use just single dot to compute the
constructor run
and then using that one dof rom we are
going to evaluate error estimate at
whole bunch of points in the parameter
space
we are going to find a point where the
rom performs a prorest
and then compute the finite element
solution at that point
we are going to perform adaptive mesh
refinement at that point as necessary
such that snapshot is accurate
we then update the reduced spaces and
retrain these reduced quadrature rules
using empirical quadrature procedure
and then we basically keep adding points
every every iteration we basically probe
the part of the parameter space that is
least well approximated as informed by
this error estimate and then keep adding
points until the user prescribed error
tolerance is met for all of the training
points
okay
so that's how this simultaneous finite
element reduce spaces and reduce
quadrature greedy training procedure
work
and going back to the initial discussion
of the approximation hierarchy what this
method is really trying to do is to
control all three sources of the error
associated with the finite element
approximation so this comes from the
finite mesh
reduce basis error which comes from the
use of finite reduced spaces and reduce
quadrature error which comes from the
use of the reduced quadrature rule
and we have a mechanism for controlling
each of these three sources of error and
also mechanism for estimating these
sources of error
so this enables automatic construction
of the rom in the sense that we provide
problem description and users specify
the target error tolerance for the
quantity of interest say one percent on
lift or drug
and then the algorithm is going to
automatically train the finite element
space reduce basis space and reduce
quadrature to create a certified rom
i put certified here in quotes because
we don't have error bounds these are
simply estimates um but we'll see how
these methods work
so let's revisit this honorarium 6
problem again so we have two parameters
angle attack and mach number reynolds
number is fixed and as a user i'm going
to provide a geometry and say that i
want surrogate model to achieve one
percent error level
and at this point the algorithm takes
over
and first going to basically perform
adaptive mesh refinement to make sure
that all of the snapshots needs the user
prescribed error tolerance
in terms of the
drug error and i'd like to again
emphasize that these high order adaptive
methods are quite a bit more efficient
than just using second order method on
best practice measures
so that's how we control the finite
element error now in terms of the
reduced basis error this is what we
observe in terms of the error estimate
against the number of basis function so
in that greedy iteration where we keep
adding more nodes or sorry more training
points basically error goes down as we
add more training points
we terminate after adding ninth point
number of degrees of freedom goes down
from about one point one million to nine
and number of quarter points goes down
from six point three million to about
now we can test this method on a set of
test points which are different from the
trend set and here is what we observe
so blue line here corresponds to the
actual error computed at the set of test
points which are different from the
training point and we see that yes the
error does come down quite rapidly
perhaps even more encouraging is the
orange line which is the error estimate
so this is an error estimate that can be
computed in online efficient manner and
we see that their estimate is quite
effective in the sense that it predict
the three true error in a reduced order
model even though this is invoked a test
set which are different from the
training set
now we can talk a little bit more about
computational cost to characterize that
i'm going to use a wall clock time
associated with a single finite element
so on the adapted mesh as a single time
unit so this doesn't involve the time
required perform actual adaptation just
solving the problem on that final
optimized mesh
now in terms of total offline cost it
requires about 60 times a single solve
of the finite element
much of the cost comes from performing
this adaptive digi approximation for all
of the snapshots and making sure each
one of those snapshots are accurate
and second dominant cost comes from this
identification of the reduced quadrature
rule using this training algorithm
but once we pay that we achieve
significant speed up in the online stage
if we want to just evaluate the output
speed up is in the order of 22 000 in
world clock time if we want to evaluate
both output and error estimate it's
about 21 000.
now in terms of cpu speed up it's even
greater because there's certain parallel
efficiency loss for this small reduced
order model when we try to use many
cores
so that was basically uh um kind of the
set of tools we use to construct these
reduced order models so now i'd like to
briefly talk about number of different
applications of this cluster method so
first is extension to moderate and high
dimensional problems
um assumption that i'm going to make is
that problem is still reducible in a
sense that even if the extrinsic
dimensions large the intrinsic dimension
is still small
even if we make this assumption though
there are a number of challenges so
first of all we have to ensure that
model is accurate for all training set
training parameters sorry all parameters
in this high dimensional space
and sleek on the ball we have to control
the offline training cost when you're
training in this high dimensional space
and i think one way to approach this
problem is to adaptively construct this
training parameter set such that we can
tackle these moderate to high
dimensional problems
okay
so what we want to do so there are two
goals so first of all we want our
training set that sufficiently covers
this high dimensional space
but at the same time we want to make
sure that our training time doesn't blow
up because we are using a very large
training set and we combine three
ingredients to address this challenge so
first of all we use this online
efficient error estimate
as i mentioned our rom achieves order of
thousand plus speed up so that means
that we can use sampling point maybe a
thousand points or so in the parameter
space without too much issues
second is that we are going to
adaptively refine this training set
during the greedy iteration such that we
can focus the sampling um sampling the
region of the parameter space that has
large errors
and lastly we are going to perform
adaptive enrichment of these hyper
reduced training points such that we can
construct a reduced order model
efficiently
so i'd like to show an example of this
for a uh uncertainty quantification of
the range flow so we are here looking at
the flow of a ra 2822 airfoil
and our parameters are seven dimensional
so it's a moderate dimensional problems
and these are the parameters associated
with the spalatal mars turbulence model
what we would like to do is to
understand how the variability in these
parameters affect the drug prediction
now one thing i would like to emphasize
is that in the context of uq it is
important to control the discretization
error
in a careful manner such that we don't
conflate the error due to the model and
error due to the discretization
for this reason we are going to actually
control the discussion era to be less
than one percent for all parameter
values even though the actual variation
in the drug for this particular problem
tends to be around 20 percent
so let's take a look at how it works so
again we are trying to control all
sources of error in terms of the finite
element error using adaptive scheme we
can reduce the error from 23 to about
0.25 percent with a very small increase
in the number of degrees of freedom
and on the right i'm showing you the
training history for this radius basis
approximation so this silver line
corresponds to the maximum error
obtained on an adaptively chosen
training set which is about 400 points
and we see that it terminates after
about 24 basis functions are chosen
number of degrees of freedom goes down
from about 64 000 to 24. quadrature
point goes down from 104 000 to about
five hundred
now we can check if this method in fact
solved the high dimensional problem
correctly
checking it on a set of test points here
we use test set of 20 test points and
plot the worst case error
blue line again corresponds to the vast
era and we can see that error actually
does come down and in fact it is bounded
by the error obtained over the training
set
orange curve corresponds to the error
estimate so again error estimate works
quite well even though the
even in this high dimensional space and
this is one of the key ingredients that
allows us to explore high dimensional
space relatively efficiently
now in terms of training cost i have to
admit that it is quite expensive overall
training cost is about 200 times just a
single finite element solved and we are
trying to improve this computational
cost right now
but in terms of the online acceleration
we achieve about the fact of 300 speed
up including the evaluation of this
error estimate which is quite accurate
we can extend this to time dependent
problems as well
so here
we are going to look at example of flow
past a naka double o 12 air foil
equations lamina navia stoke
angle attack is very high 20 degrees
that's why the flow is separated we are
going to treat reynolds number as a
parameter
and our output of interest is time
averaged drug
now in terms of methodology everything
we talked about can be extended to these
unsteady problems so we can still use
the greedy type training to construct
reduced basis space except now we are
going to combine that with pod
we can also use this type of sparse
quality identification technique
and finally for error estimation and
control we appeal to spectrum
formulation and unsteady adjunct so for
this particular problem adjoint looks
something like this so it's solved
backward in time and it still tells us
which region of the flow is most
important to compute the quantity of
interest accurately
so let's take a look at how this method
works again we perform adaptive mesh
refinement to control the finite element
error
on the right i'm showing you the change
in the reduce basis error and in this
case we just need three training points
over the reynolds number space
and era goes down and meet the user
prescribed target error tolerance
in terms of the size of the model it
goes down from about 160 000 to 42
number of quadrature points goes down
from 320 000 to about 1000 so we achieve
rapid convergence over the training set
in terms of prediction performance it's
not quite as good as what we see for the
steady state problems so blue line
corresponds to actual era orange line
corresponds to error estimate notice
that their estimate is not quite as
sharp as what we have seen for steady
state problem nevertheless it's still
indicative of the error we have
in terms of speed up we achieve about
the fact of 330 speed up in wall clock
and if we want to also compute the error
estimate speed up is about a factor of
240.
now once we have this type of unsteady
problem capability we can also use the
other application oh sorry one more
slide so this is just a
time instantaneous history of drag and
lift and we see that it can predict
these quantities i should know that
instantaneous quantity approximation
typically is not as good as time average
quantity approximation but nevertheless
it rises around two percent for this
case
now once we have this kind of uh
unsteady flow simulation capability we
can also try to use it in the context of
data assimilation
so here the goal is to combine imperfect
non-linear dynamical model and noisy
sparse and incomplete data to estimate
state of physical system one example we
all know is whether prediction where we
combine say with global circulation
model and whether station data to
predict the state what we would like to
do is to bring such a capability to
engineering systems and emphasis here
that we want to make sure that data
simulation methods can meet practical
turnaround and resource demands of
engineering setting we can't afford to
run the simulation on the thousands of
cores consistently so we want to really
reduce the computational cost
now one way to solve this problem is to
use ensembl common filter so here we
basically this is an ensemble method so
initially estimate the error using monte
carlo type approximation
and then we generate initial set of
approximations in the forecast stage we
are going to propagate each one of these
guys for in time
until we take the measurement at this
point
and when we take the measurement we
update the state and that's called
analysis stage
now one of the key to computing this
update correctly is that we have to
compute the common gain accurately
and computing the common gain accurately
means that we have to compute these
covariances accurately and accuracy of
the covariance depends on the size of
the
ensemble that we are using
so in order to ensemble common field
that work well we have to use
sufficiently large number of ensemble
such that we can compute the covariance
correctly
but
obviously the computational cost goes up
as we try to use large number of
ensemble so what we would like to do is
to replace much of this ensemble with a
reduced order model approximation and
that's the idea behind the multi-level
enc based on florida model and reduced
order model
so we run the floater model to compute
the solutions
we train the wrong using those full
order model samples and then we run a
whole bunch of wrong simulations
and then at the analysis stage we are
going to incorporate data perform
multi-level update that incorporates
information from form rom and
observations
and then again perform form solution
from abstract update retrain the rom
perform the wrong solutions and so on
so
and then update the state again at the
next time step
now i'd like to illustrate how this
particular method work we are going to
look at the same problem but now we are
going to treat initial condition as
uncertain okay
and then random output uh
uh
uncertain and then we are going to
basically take observation of about
every every one fourth oscillation
period
so this is a preliminary result but this
is typically how data simulation method
work so this is relative l2 error
against time
and this is a result obtained using 64
full order model samples so this is
about as good as it gets
every time we make that takes a
measurement error goes down and the
error slowly converges
for this particular case i'm also
showing the shaded region because the
performance of the filter changes
there's some randomness in the filter so
i'm showing you the performance we
obtained for the 10 percent um
within the 10 to 90 percent percentile
this is about as many as we get but this
method is very expensive because we have
to solve the full order model 64 times
if we try to reduce that and just use
four solves you can see that the
performance gets far worse than weight
was
so this is cheap but not as well
if we use eight instead
again it's cheap um but still doesn't
perform that well
but if we use multi-level method we get
basically this purple curve now the cost
for using this multi-level method is
comparable to this may cause 8
approximation which is showing yellow
line
but notice that in terms of the error it
achieves error comparable to the image
equals 64 case except towards the very
end
so what this multi-level acceleration
allows us to do
is to basically reduce the computational
cost required to achieve a given
accuracy so this is just one application
of the rom in the context of
ensemble-based data assimilation
okay so that basically concludes my talk
um so in today's talk we talked about
goal-oriented rom for non-linear pds
based on this adaptive high order method
reduce basis approximation deal with the
residual error estimate and this
empirical quadrature procedure hyper
reduction
and really the emphasis was to quantify
and control various sources of the error
and in our case we consider the control
of the finite element error reduce basis
error as well as the error due to the
use of reduced quadrature rule
and the goal was that user can just
supply the target tolerance and the
entire trans process should be automated
and i showed an example of this type of
technology for parameter design sweep
uncertainty quantification and study
flows and data assimilation
so thank you very much for coming to the
talk and i can take any questions
thank you thank you so much for the
great talk massa i i really loved it um
i mean i
i i should say i i especially love your
point wise uh um iq method um i'm very
interested in
uh knowing more more about that okay
let's do i have a q and a sessions uh we
do have a question from the
the chat room in emmanuel
from emmanuel um
yes how close the the parameters used in
the simulations are to actual values did
the reduction seems always to be related
to spatial coordinates
would we look at the fourier components
of the fields involved in a spectral
method or prototype i i think the okay
what he remembers a method is a
singular value
i guess okay okay let's see yeah i'm
seeing that i just opened the chat so i
can read this as well so
uh
how close the parameters using
simulations are to actual
values uh
for the prediction case i guess oh i see
okay i understand yes so
so points are chosen randomly whenever i
do test so very much the how far they
are depends on the
extent of the parameter space um
so
uh
right so for example uh
let's see so the earlier example we
looked at yes for example mach number
point three to point five and then of
attack of zero to three when i do test
i'm just choosing points randomly so i
think uh in this case i was choosing
product five points or so to test
randomly the point so the distance
is entirely um based on this
the choice of the parameter domain and
i'm always plotting the worst case error
so the largest error obtained at the
largest um
the largest error obtained over the test
set
uh
so that's the largest error is less than
one percent
right that that was always my goal yes
that's correct uh reduction seems to be
always related to spatial code rate um
could we look at
three components of the field involving
a spectrum method approach so this is a
very uh very interesting question so
there's a i think very tight connection
between spectral method and types of
reduced basis method that
i presented today or we have been seeing
in these
gdps seminars um i think one key
difference is that
in spectral method the basis functions
are still constructed in a program in a
sense program agnostic manners these are
polynomial spaces that can in general
approximate any function that might you
know it might encounter
here i think the emphasis is on the fact
that we are using empirical or tailored
basis in the sense that these basis
functions are targeted for the
particular parametric variation that
problem exhibit so um i think i think
there's a very tight connection i've
never actually looked at uh the spectrum
for this uh
these uh for example these uh these
particularly spaces but there's
certainly a connection between the two
but the physics is involved when we're
using dimensions
frequencies
yes so i completely agree with this
remark so in a way this type of
approximation you know it's not treating
all the features in a same manner things
like you know boundary layer plays an
important role so um in a sense i think
emphasis more emphasis is placed on
those particular features i don't know
if i'm doing a particularly good job
answering the questions but uh hopefully
that was okay
he says thumbs up
okay so you did a good job okay next
question uh
is from han
and he asked the adjoin equation is
quantitatively interesting dependent
right
uh what if we
care only the carbohydrate instead of a
specific quantity of interest can we
still formulate the abstract equation so
no so in that case adjoint wouldn't be
the uh um i guess the right approach to
the problem we want to use as you say
you know if you have more of the energy
norm type quantity then we might want to
use more of the energy type
error error estimate and control say h1
norm of the error or something like that
um one thing i wanted to emphasize here
though is that we focused on quantity of
interest because in things like
aerodynamic flows those are the things
people typically care about things like
lift and drug and so on so that was um i
guess our emphasis in this particular
talk uh but
you absolutely right um you know
different formulation would be required
to control global error and in fact
we've actually done that in some other
works um
for example if you are looking at you
know more of the elasticity type
problems and so on you know there you
might actually have things like you know
total strain as year and so on that
might be that might be a little more
engineering relevant so we have also
done work in that area as well but uh um
i didn't really talk about this in this
talk here i really focused on
aerodynamics and controlling the error
due to uh some quantity of interest
or error quantity of interest
yeah
that's great i think with a
excellent answer
okay i don't i see any more questions
from
the chat room but i do have some
questions while i'm asking questions you
guys can
post your question in chat room
so
um
obviously
the point-wise
iq
method is a lot more efficient
element-wise iq i can definitely see
that
um
have you compare
have you done some comparison between
the element-wise iq with a
some some other hyper-reduction
technique
like like a ti-n and
ganet etc yeah so that's that's an
excellent question so no we haven't done
explicit comparison um
but what i can say is that basically
um
all of the algebraic based reduction
methods so things like dim
yeah they all require they work at
algebraic level yeah in the end right so
all of those methods in a sense have to
work with element as a working unit
effectively because you still have to be
able to compute the residual associated
with the full order model degrees of
freedom which means that you used to
have to perform integration over
elements and so on so that limitation of
having to work with elements still
still exists in this type of discrete or
any algebraic type hyper-reduction
methods and i feel that we have to peel
basically one level deeper in a sense
that go one more one one more level
intrusive to uh
to you know do point wise type recons uh
approximation if we want to
our method to work really well for
high-order approximation because
you know the coyote approximation
especially in the three-dimensional
space single element can contain you
know a lot of degrees of freedom right
so that's that's basically the um
limitation we have um at least for this
dg type method
right right right uh well i mean that's
really relevant to what we are uh trying
to solve at
now
do you know
mfm by the way
um it's understandable
and and then um it's the software uh the
higher order functional element uh
software uh developed at lawrence level
yes yes i think i think he actually
mentioned this to me before and uh yeah
so here i'm i'm not really building on
mfm here i'm just uh
digi solver but uh i mean obviously the
concept discussed here applies to any
high order method as well right so right
right well i i don't know i i might want
to introduce you to um some of the mdm
teams um
maybe you guys can collaborate on a full
auto model
size
just in terms of the high uh higher the
final one and then dg method
um
there might be some um
way collaboration future collaboration
can be done uh yeah
i'm very excited yes suddenly yes please
let me know yeah
i'm sure they will be interested
knowing more about your work okay so
while we are talking uh another question
from uh
okay
the split between fluid model error and
reduce to model error tolerance was 0.5
each if the goal is very rapid online
computation and offline cost is less
significant
seems to make sense to change the limits
so that form limit is lower yeah and
wrong limit is higher
if
yeah so yeah um yeah so that's a good
point i've kind of arbitrary chosen the
split of 0.5 percent for both but yes
depending on exactly where the emphasis
is for example if you cared more about
creating the smallest rom then yes you
might actually reduce the formula such
that you can commit little more room
errors and so on um here we didn't
really do any optimization of that kind
um and in the end it doesn't make that
significant of difference only because
error tends to go down exponentially
with n so
um
that convergence is quite fast so
difference between between point five
percent and one percent might not be
that significant uh hopefully that
answers your question
great
yeah he's smiling
so that's great um
all right
so
um
you're not doing
any adaptive refinements um i mean
you're doing the relative requirements
um
uh
you're not doing other tv refine
let me rephrase you're doing you're not
doing adductive refinements um in
unsteady uh like in thai marching uh
sense right well uh so i'm not doing any
online adaptive refinement not the kind
of stuff you know that kevin did i'm not
doing that but the mesh refinement
itself we do do it so i guess it's kind
of hard to see maybe i need to maximize
this again but uh
yeah so the same principle applies we
can still use dual weighted residual
method and compute the error and then
perform adaptations so you know you can
see that the elements are refined in a
selective manner i guess uh yeah that is
for the steady problem but i'm i was
talking about honestly this is a study
problem this is a steady problem oh that
is a study problem
yes yes but one thing we don't do is
that we don't we use we perform mesh
refinement but in the end we use the
same mesh for all time snapshots and
just so that we can simplify the
computation of uh you know pod and so on
um
so it's not dynamic it's a static mesh
but it is refined in uh
it is refined in adaptive manner yeah i
see i see okay
well how about that in dynamic sense
let's say you the other tip alignment
has been done in dynamic sense and
yeah so the only it's not really a huge
challenge but if you do dynamic
refinement then each one of the
snapshots can potentially line up
different on a different mesh right so
in order to
actually perform things like pod you
have to work on the common mesh so you
might have to construct at least a pair
of pairwise common mesh to compute all
the inner product associated with pod um
we've done this for uh um
much simpler problems 2d problems and so
on but
right now we don't do this for
aerodynamic flows partially because when
you support an isotropic mesh refinement
where you don't just refine the
isotropic manner but like you might
split in one direction only and so on um
it becomes much more difficult to solve
this pairwise matching problem so um we
we are not really doing that
um i don't think there's any conceptual
or mathematical challenge to doing that
um it's just mechanics we don't we don't
have the mechanics to do it so yeah
let's see
yeah
maybe one last question in slide 31 um
you mentioned that you you're trying to
improve the offline cost um yeah
and
can you um
can you um discuss a little bit what
what's the approach you are taking right
now to improve that offline course
yeah
so number of different things so so
first of all i think what i presented
here is not really optimized in any way
so the i mean the fact still remains
that uh we have to use in a relatively
large training set because it's a high
dimensional space i don't think there's
a really good way to cover it using a
small number of sets so that fact
remains but there are things we can do
in terms of for example
so hyper reduction right now is actually
quite expensive in a sense that uh
especially in high dimensional space
when you have lots of training points uh
identifying this reduced quadrature rule
becomes quite expensive so we're trying
to improve both just not just the speed
but also the accuracy of that process so
we're trying to make it a little more
robust and i think those actually small
things can make quite a bit of
difference for even higher dimensional
spaces we might actually need to
consider more formal dimensionality
reduction so reduction of the parameter
space before you do the reduction of the
um
well the reduction of the parameter
space itself but we haven't really
um
looked too much into it or integrated
that with the rest of our um um greedy
algorithms and so on so um yeah it's
very much working progress i just wanted
to note that this is not certainly not a
solved problem i know many people work
on high dimensional problems and uh
there's still a lot of challenge there i
think um yeah i totally understood um i
i just wanted to um you know know what
approach you're
you're taking
to solve that challenging problem um
all right
yeah the other big challenge is you know
transgenic flows flows with shocks you
know you talked about this in the last
ddps seminar and you know people martin
thomas also i think talked about in
earlier seminars as well i think that's
a huge huge problem we are just starting
to uh get into that but uh nothing to
show yet so yeah i see i see all right
um
if if you have anything to show please
let me know also that i i can invite you
again okay all right well thank you so
much for inviting me and thank you
everybody for coming to the talk so yeah
thank you massa thank you so much for
the great talk um i hope i i'm sure the
audiences uh have enjoyed your talk
right now a lot of people left already
because it's past uh
yeah yeah all the time in that time
but i'm sure they enjoyed it
well with that let's conclude uh our
ddps seminar uh talk today uh thank you
so much masa again no thank you
it's nice seeing you as well bye-bye and
thank you thank you everyone
masa i